You know the senate keep shining
the window keep blowing. The rain.
You keep falling. These are all
things that keep happening for.
As long as there's life on
earth you know that we don't.
We don't need to have these insane
power systems that pollute the planet
and require lots of maintenance
and stuff anymore.
You know the technology is
there today to provide power.
At once fingertips without having
to having to fly once guts out
in order to maintain a systems.
Well. Back in the 70s
or even further back in the 60s a lot
of people like myself how these views
of.
The world as it was not being able to
sustain itself very much longer a lot of
other people in mainstream society would
say listen to these crazy hippies with
their stupid ideas you know.
They were to come back to reality and
see what it's all about but. Over.
It's amazing. Over the last 20 years.
How how people's acceptance of.
The fact that we can keep on going the
way we were has changed. You know.
Now where we are as an
extremist 20 years ago.
Now my ideas are accepted everywhere.
You know so i think there's been
some some amazing change. Is there.
The problem is that. Although
people are all aware of what.
Of the shortcomings of
society is as it stands.
There's still not very many people are
really prepared to change their own life.
You know they all agree with the
fact that something needs to be done
but most people seem to be waiting
for somebody else to lead the way.
And i guess that's what the rainbow tower
companies about we are trying to say look
it's all here it's all available
when she just do it now. You know.
And unfortunately one of the obstacles
that we're still against at the moment is
that in this city suburban environment our
power systems are not cost competitive
with the grid system.
They would be a lot more cost compared if
the grid system was incorporated all the
real costs of the system
which i don't do anyway.
We are cost competitive
in the rural environment.
It's a pity
that we're not a cost competitive message
environment i guess that's just only a
matter of time.
Even even with the cross-subsidisation
of systems the way they are today.
If that doesn't change we will still
become cost competitive in the next decade
or so just because
technology is improving and.
Renewable energy systems are
improving all the time.
Through.
Some of our own products.
They're aimed at our company products
that we have for sale include
the micro-hydro system and
when i was telling you there. We also.
Develops a sine wave inverter. An
inverter is something that gives you.
I've all the js 8 like 240 volts
i say from a battery supply.
Most inverters that are available
are well known as modified square.
Step 2 square wave inverters the problem
with with those way forms out of the
inverters is a lot of standard 240
volt equipment doesn't like it.
And we felt that there was a.
Great need in the marketplace for
a sine wave inverter so we went
and developed their own sign my
finger which turns out to be a very.
Furtively indestructible product which we
believe it's one of the best inverters in
the market.
And any standard 240 volt equipment within
the wattage rating of the invertible
will run very happily off it.
We are now in the process of
making a large inverter the one
that we had so far was a
300 watt 12 oz inverter.
We're now developing a 600 watt inverter
that's also got some other added features.
It'll actually reverse as
a battery charge as well.
And we believe it's going
to be a lot more efficient
and then this more than there is.
Change. And yeah.
It's. I always like to keep power system
to simple as possible and from it with
that in mind it seems a lot more sensible
if you have a battery bank have things
that runs rector of the battery bank
than to have things stand to fortify the
places for which you need
an inverter the problem is
that the semi different pieces of equipment
a tape might want to have some of them
probably very difficult if not
impossible to obtain as a d.c.
Appliance and we're not in
the business of trying.
I to think of every possible appliance
and making an alternative available.
We tell people about the
alternatives that we know about
and occasionally some of the more popular
products will actually go out of her way
to try and either.
Source an alternative one or
manufacture one ourselves
but we're mainly about setting up power
systems not about supplying appliances
as well.
What we usually recommend
to people is to have.
They say lighting as much as possible
and use they say appliances
wherever possible
but we're they say appliances aren't
available then you'd probably just get your
standard a c appliance and
run it via an inverter so.
So then we want to make an
inverter available that
that will give the minimum of problem
with running these appliances.
We have had problems with they
say appliances in the past.
Every once in a while we
come across a really good.
12 out of appliance and
we start selling it
and then six months a year down
the track. We discover that.
The people that are doing
importing or manufacturing
that particular appliance don't
feel this a big enough marketplace.
They're not selling enough of a minute.
Sorry to discontinue they
even though they were.
We were doing really well with
them so. That's unfortunate but.
I guess our power systems are
will be as dependable as what we
are you know i don't see the companies
going to go down and there is always.
It's actually quite
amazing. You know where.
Other small businesses have
started in the forward.
Probably 90 per cent of businesses a bit
in recent years they've started forward
within a year or so.
Here we are growing at a phenomenal rate
not seeing any end of the growth rate.
Goes on and so the way things are
looking i could say that the rain
that i can hear and hear this day.
You know we're going to get bigger
and bigger as time goes on.
Yeah yeah. It is an anarchistic i guess.
I mean. It's interesting the word energy
is often seen to main total chaos.
You know but yet.
If you look at the way we're running here
or even though there were either all shapes
are all indians nobody really knows was.
We've got a working relationship
here that really does work.
You know we we all know who to see about
what and who to communicate with and.
It all seems to happen
next. Exceptionally well.
As i was saying we've got
a structure whereby.
We don't have a that
pyramid structure at all.
Everybody's on the same level
we all learn the same wage.
No matter what you do we all
have an equal opportunity
in having some say in what goes
on in the company. So i guess.
I guess one of the things that
makes it work is the fact that.
We all are left with the responsibility.
Each one of this is got the responsibility
you know it's not be can't pass
responsibility onto somebody else. We all.
I guess take their children that each
and every one of this is
a bit like a foreman.
You know we've got to make sure the job
is done and the job is done properly
and the fact that we.
Wear your shareholders we are all part
owners of the company gives a very direct
interest in what goes on with the company.
Yes. Well i don't know.
I guess we all.
We're all really proud of the company you
know we all really like what we're doing
we all we all have great
regard for each other.
Things and again and.
But you know it's cut.
It's out there. Can't you.
Gives you question again. Well i
think we have an incentive here.
You can say nobody's going
to get rich but i guess.
Well or prosperous the
company prospers altogether.
You know at the moment we're getting very
low wage rates just because we can't
afford to increase wage rates as yet
but hopefully in a near future.
We'll be able to increase it.
And as a company prospers our wage
rates of an increase in altogether.
The fact that we know
that there's not not somebody amongst us
who is making enormous amount of profits
on.
Sacrificing everybody else makes us
feel much happier you know we know
that we're all equal.
And it's quite amazing how we roll.
And the level of commitment within the
company is actually quite astounding.
You know if you look at other companies
and you look at the staff turnover.
We've been going for for four years and
their staff turnover is incredibly low.
You know most people that come
and join us here this day.
You know they're happy here and not
really keen to move on. Anywhere else.
I know for myself that i've worked
at all sorts of jobs in my life
and most those jobs.
I didn't really want to know i
wasn't happy with them you know
and pattaya the reason for not being
happy with those jobs because they were
damaging to the environment and the
fact that i knew i was doing a job
that was destructive
didn't make me feel good.
You know and the fact that
i was working for a boss
and i didn't have to have any chance
of steering the company in different
directions
or anything just made me lose interest in
it you know whereas i think the way we've
set up this company here.
There's every incentive for people
to speak up to be involved.
People can feel good about it because
because we're doing something
that we believe is good for the environment
we're about setting about creating
change in public awareness and
creating change in. Stand.
Well i was going to talk
about standards of living.
Creating a change in the lifestyle.
You know the thing about
standard of living is
that it's often quite meaningless you
know what really matters to us is
quality of life. You know the
fact that that you've got.
Toilet paper with with pretty
flowers printed on it you know.
Does not improve one's quality of life but
that is saying to improve the standard
of living you know the idea of stand of
living is quite nonsensical.
I think my quality of life
is probably very high.
I mean i don't know nobody is going around
sort of comparing people's quality of
life that i know of
but although there is a lot of study
being done on standard of living
and standards of living a based in time.
All the on profit in turn over no that's
still the stuff it doesn't you know people
can be totally miserable.
Caught up in a rat race
doing a job they don't like
and yet their standard of living
could be seen to be very high.
You know but but their quality
of life is just down the drain.
And the way that that we are
here i think that we're all.
As i was saying before
we don't earn very much.
But we're living in a rural environment.
With we've got clean air
fresh water around us.
Beautiful views.
We can do what we want we've all free
individuals we are not working on the buses.
We're getting basically what we need.
And i think that makes our quality
of life very high. You know.
Even though there is something much
a stand of living is not so high.
Yeah. As you can see we've got
power lines only 50 meters away.
We decided when we don't. This place that.
This is around new ram
attack on any premises.
That way we were not going
to connect to the grid.
And we were going to provide
all our own power for it.
And that is done by way of about
50 solar panels on the roof.
And then winter going out the back
and the standby generator if neither
of those work very well. Is that.
This building is also incorporating
passive solar design.
And we've got most of the glass facing
north being in the southern hemisphere the
sunshine gin. You know from the north.
We've got eaves over all these
wind is calculated to let the sun.
Oh and then over the winter months but to
keep the sand out over the summer months.
The building as a space story ended.
So that. Yeah we've got a lot of
thermal mass in the building.
We've got that. 600 tons of
mud brick in the building.
I think and concrete floors that
when the sand penetrates into the
building over the winter months.
All that thermal mass heats up
and maintains its heat for
a long period of time so
that the building tends to retain
its heat over the winter months.
Over the summer months.
The sun doesn't shine in so all this
ever mistake is relatively cool and
and keeps a fairly constant cool temperature
over the summer months we've also got
a fairly high roof in the building which
allows us to to utilize to some extent.
What you call the chimney effect as
fake you know thermal updrafts and.
So
that it's possible to open up there is of the
building where the cool air can be allowed
in and as the air heats up. It moves out
through through the vents in the roof.
Those vents in the roof can be closed
off. So that in the winter months.
You can maintain heat within the
building in the summer months.
You can just allow the airflow
to keep building cool.
We've got a i think you've seen the.
Courtyard.
We've got a courtyard within the building
totally surrounded by the building which
is got no roof over it.
So it's an open area but
within the building and
that helps to let more light into the
building because of the size of the building
and it also allows us to ventilate
the building more adequately.
Name been this scene as the the
alternative capital of australia.
I think niman is a very
unique place and name
and uniqueness is lended itself to setting
up the room but the company here.
A lot more successfully than we could
have done anywhere else in the country.
Nimbin is famous for being
famous. So to speak.
You know we keep getting media
being attracted here all the time
and most of the time they have to the
forgotten why they're coming here but it's.
Just keep coming here.
And i think that that has helped
us to a great extent you know.
We've got in this area we have a lot
of really committed people people with
great environmental awareness.
And people who are really keen
on trying out new experiments.
I think
that looking for people with those qualities
elsewhere in the country would be a
lot had an image in your
area. We've got every.
You call skill they can possibly think of.
Within a 20 mile radius of nimbin so with
every skill you can think of you probably
don't have to go very far to find it you
know i know people around here that
that were a nuclear
physicist etc. You know.
I just didn't want to be part of
that anymore so i decided to
come to nimbin so so i think
that nimbin does attract
the kind of people that
that helps to make the rain
with their company work.
Yeah. Yeah there is definitely. Yeah yeah.
Nimbin again niman is very
unusual in so many respects.
Even though they say we're in
a site here that's not all
that good for for installation
for for solar power. Yes.
Nimbin as cut probably out of all the
residents no more than 50 per cent of them
are living on their own
standalone power systems
and most of those living on
entirely solar power systems.
So there's a very strong
awareness in this area of
environmental issues in a lot of people
that move here do not want
to know about grid power.
Also people who do not want
to know about about standard.
Water carrier siri systems know sort of
stuff we've had a great dispute nimbleness
recently over the the nimbin
syringe scheme. You know.
The a lot of the townsfolk wanted it.
Very much. I think through ignorance.
You know because.
If anything the syringe system because it's
only been around for 100 years you know
there were to carry it up
serious system but yet this day
and age it's taken for granted.
You know
that if you want a serious system with a
carry serious system is the only way to go.
And unfortunately in australia it's been
very few towns set up with any anything
else. So there's no other
example for people to turn to.
So when when there was
a lot of talk in them
and about us having a serious system here.
So many people said are you ok i will
carry serious justin because that's what
everybody immediately thinks of.
So well.
A lot of the the alternative type
people do not live in the town she.
If they live in the surrounding areas
and most of these people do not like
to see a water carrier syringe system.
You know
and particularly now we've been hearing
so much lately about blue green algae
pollution of river systems and ocean
pollution through asian outflows
and that's the stuff.
And also you have a stray is
generally a very dry continent
and just seems crazy that out
of our top quality water
that we should be flushing 35 to 50 per
cent of it down the dunny you know.
We're here at the rain
but our company we decided to
go for a dry composting toilet.
You know so you're not you're
not flushing the dunny at all.
There's no water involved in the process.
We also have a self-sufficient
with water here.
We all there was a
requirement for the room
but the company collected
off the roof here.
We don't do not connect to the nimbin
water supply system. But anyway.
Going back to those talking about.
The with with the syringe
system in them and i think
that there were other options
there and particularly one option
that would have been very very much cheaper
to this syringe game that's now going
into serious games costing about three
million dollars. We could have put in.
Dry compress posting to this nature
home. For a fraction of that cost.
And then of course no further.
Bills or anything down the line.
Other than just just a small
collection say you know i think
that every six months possibly
an employee of their own
but our company even could have just gone
around and emptied the field containers.
You know the thing about dry composting
toilets is what comes out of them is not in
any way unpleasant. It's what.
Comes out it is actually
a very rich soft soil.
You know humus it's it's it's a very
crumbly soft soil it's it's actually.
It's no different to. The best so
that you find in the garden anywhere.
You know so. If you wait.
If you've got a dry compassing toilet itself
to decay for at least nine months then
then what you've got to deal with there
is actually a very valuable commodity.
It's actually a saleable commodity
price whereas what we're doing now.
I'm not sure whether we're thinking
about trying to sell the byproduct.
But the problem is with standard
always carries syringe systems is
that the byproduct is still likely to
be contaminated with all sorts of human
passage and. Whereas with
a dry composting toilet.
Every human pathogen other than possibly
around we're makes has been destroyed in
the process. So there's nothing
that compares with with
with composting for for.
Getting rid of passage
and if you get frustrated.
Like. You know.
You know.
Well if you ask around and
about as a success story.
I think everybody would point to the rain
that our company first thing
you know so i think that.
There are things happening around them
and that everybody is proud of the way
that i feel about things i've i've had
this feeling for a long long time.
I remember when i was. As a
teenager or in my early 20s
and seeing all these demonstrations
around the place you know anti vietnam
demonstrations of this stuff.
And all these demonstrations
to me seemed to be wrong.
They seem to be throwing
aggression at violence.
You know throwing more violence
in the direction of violence.
To me if you wanted to
demonstrate something.
What you want to be demonstrating is how
to do it not how not to do with you know
so i guess that's what my life has been
all about you know i've always wanted to
demonstrate the positive not the negative.
So the rain but our company
is an example of that.
I think
that we're through here trying to demonstrate
not necessarily what's wrong with how
everybody else is doing it.
But how to do it correctly.
And i think that you know nimbin
it's got all sorts of positive
and negative aspects to it.
But i'd like to focus more on the positive
and not take so much
notice of the negative.
Hence our address yeah
one alternative way.
We had a straight here didn't have a name
to it so decide to give their own. Etc..